there are many questions on these
options very questions yeah it's tough
you just don't know if we got Michael
this lady over here okay I'm really good
question yeah um
howdy transferred the mortgage what are
you doing like a repayment mortgage how
do you convert that to you sure sure
great question so in terms of the
mortgage it depends on what the current
setup is so what usually you'll do is
you'll get them to contact their I like
interest only all of my properties or
anything just only so if it's on
repayment if you take the property on
and you just keep it on repayment you're
effectively you wouldn't want to do that
unless you're very confident you going
to buy the house because you're paying
down the mortgage so I would much rather
everything beyond interest only and you
can get them to switch it but how it
works in terms of who pays the mortgage
is you've got a few options best option
is if they bring up the mortgage company
and they just say hey I'm changing my
account details it's going to be coming
from a new bank
let me pass you over to Samuel needs and
he'll give you the details it's like
paying someone's load officially you
follow and it's just like paint
someone's phone bill like if I want to
pay your phone bill
as long as it's game playing I can pay
it so that already works some lenders
will say no no the mortgages in your
name so just put in your bank if they
say that then what you need to do is let
the let the owner continue paying the
mortgage and UV burst of each month
but if you do that make sure that you
get quarterly statements to make sure
that actually the mortgage they are
using it to pay the mortgage so they're
the two options so would you advise that
if you can't get it transferred to with
him and only you should walk away it
depends on the deal but interest only is
definitely favorable thank you so often
to switch it if it's ready you got have
you got a lease option with someone on
repayment and I wouldn't worry about it
I just worry about sin unless you I
great right thanks B question you ever
had
yeah and obviously the reason I say that
as well as because it's here's what
here's a lot of human beings do it I did
this also is is it I call it an X Y Z
question and I say to my students don't
worry about the X Y Z just stop walk at
the Absa because the answer is always on
the other side of the hill and if you
try and think about everything there is
to know about everything to do with you
it's never gonna happen you know but I
appreciate your question
yeah go ahead my son probably a bit of a
silly question but what if the owner of
the house is living in the house how do
you take over the house and rent it out
yeah sure so what what would well they
try to do what's the owner of this house
trying to do so that so that so you can
say the same thing if you use boy gosh
if you bought if you what do they want
they want to sell it for 76 grand so if
you bought it off of the 76 ground how
much are they going to be left with in
their pocket nothing because they're
gonna use all the most powerful mortgage
so where they're gonna live and the
other thing is presumably they ain't
they know that I'm not late because
there's all that Sun in the house make
sense
so it's a great question but you're
you're just offering them what they want
they were the person that advertised the
house kind of trying to sell it what
we're relating earlier once they said I
don't know what it's not me saying well
if I buy your car afina then what are
you gonna drive I don't really care
actually there's some in the car
yeah they says yeah all right thank you
have
but any other phony questions around
around lease options yes the very back
your head man
hi Samuel and I just have a quick
question how much are solicitor these
yes okay so typically it's about 750
pounds plus VAT you can knock panceliss
different drawer up yourself or find an
online template but I would highly
suggest you don't because what will
happen is if the house goes up in value
oh yeah
at the end of the seven years you think
you're now starting to cash in and if
they say actually when I sign this I
didn't know what I was doing I was
signing under duress you're gonna be
really hard-pressed to prove that caught
I'll have a lot of people at the end of
the term and they've tried to pull out
of the deal and walk away but luckily
thank god I've always had a solicitor
represent them and draw up the contract
and that way at the end of the term if
they say I didn't know what I was doing
I can say actually you had a solicitor
representing you and I paid for that
solicitor and they represented you to
make sure that you understood what
you're doing and it was drawn up
properly so so it's really important to
do that helpful yep
give a hand go ahead yeah hey Samuel
thank you um do you have any advice and
solicitors is in what to look for in
terms of these kind of deal yeah if you
need a solicitor that does lease option
agreement because solicitors general
officers will say oh yeah I could do
that but I would always say you know do
you specialize in this and there's not
that many that don't and you know you
need to use the right kind of solicitor
and also someone that's going to be
quite fast because solicitors tend to
have to speed slow and stop so it's
Tuesday my sister's feeling porn which
goes back to how the whole the whole
thing of building your pallet in your
whole pallet is you board builders
solicitors accountants mortgage brokers
lien agents but it's really important
you have the right power team and one of
the things as well on any of our
training that we do you know on any of
our paid for training get it and the
crash courses are used to sometimes get
more power team up on stage and stuff
what used to happen is if everyone the
crash course it was just for a little
like crazy and ask them to pick their
brains and ask them questions and then
they'd be too busy to answer my calls
you know but all about math training the
deal selling masterclass the deal
finding extravaganza the Academy you you
painting on any of our training and part
of that is we give you our entire power
- oh good job yeah I some your quick
question so in terms of these lease
option agreement I'm guessing that it
will have to be in an area where the
rental potential is quite good you know
what it's exactly what we did yesterday
so before you - just because it's a free
house doesn't necessarily mean you
should do it that's what I said to my
friend over here when I said don't rush
to get one before so today because it's
always gonna be a good house so yeah if
you're doing a lease option still do the
research to speak to management still
find out how much thousands of still
find out what the benefit of course it's
got a stack I typically say the lease
option you got to make sure you cash
flows to Japan a month minimum what do
you get this Edler yeah after signing up
these questions to sell the syllabus the
cards I can't say how it is blocked so
okay so if you've got a lease option
agreement and you get a draught of
proper and this is where this list is
coming yeah like they it would be legal
for them to say you had you have the
first option on that property to buy at
that price at the time that you say so
other people desperate judge what
wanting to sell it but the comment is
it's illegal it's the law they've sold
it to you already on an option agreement
will that come up during this search the
during when they are the potential
others join in fact one seller there
will be other if it's a charge or ble
they come you're good alright go ahead
oh one more question Elise cookie yeah
okay yeah they can say it secretly yes I
summer young supposing to value only
house yes after seven years will be the
best exceeds option for your research is
to walk away just walk away
yeah here's the thing you have the
option not the obligation they have to
sell it to you they cause it's always I
have to that's the way these options
work well if they're not happy about
that in their negotiations or inaudible
I stays I say if I'm not going to buy it
I'll give you 12 months or six months
notice for you to remarket it but you
have the option not the obligation so
the option is there that you might not
buy it's not composing correct great
listen as well one more thing as well in
terms of the agent you've seen those
people gave me a weird or why don't I
cut the agent out though because that's
unethical
let me try and approach the agent direct
I'll try and get them on side never do
that because they'll always always
always get confused and when you confuse
them you lose them so what you do is you
cut the agent out I don't feel sorry for
the AG because they've been trying to
sell the house for three years right so
I cut the agent out let go direct
I do the DEA wants to do is done I'll go
back to the agent I'll tell them what I
just did how can I feel bad I did this
rent to buy scam lease option on this
property and it was long with you and I
feel really bad because obviously no no
no it's off the books could I maybe pay
your fee or something and they'd be like
well well listen here's what happened
today and rather tell them what you're
planning to do I do these options and
here's know here's what I just did with
one of your houses can I pay your fee
and what you'll find is often they're
like wow um well I got a lot more like
that
and there's certainly what happens is
they become your best free deal sources
for free houses your second deals come
to all the times it's this is your first
deal was always your hardest
[Music]
[Music]